this is a production of Cornell
University
so thank you for the invitation to come
down and speak it's a beautiful sunny
day in Ithaca so I'll try to talk
fasting and get back out there in the
sunshine so this is my title um you know
I work for a company that develops
biological seed treatments and what I
mean by that is fungi and bacteria that
you can coat the seed with plant it in
the ground in the ground and they affect
plant performance and the main fungal
species that we're working with this
Trichoderma that's what our existing
products are and and this Fido biomes
microbiome approach to research is
something that is really important in
what we do because if you think about it
what we are leveraging is the fighter
biome in our technology so this is a
brief outline of my talk and I realize
looking at this that I'm only going to
partially follow this thing's are a
little out of order but you'll figure it
out so before I jump right into things
there are a couple things I want to talk
about to the students and postdocs in
the room and the first thing is careers
and so you all may think that you know
exactly what you want to do but it's
really rare that you take that straight
line path and you end up doing what you
think you're going to do so I never
thought I would be the chief science
officer and a company and my main
messages think creatively and broadly
about what your career options are and
the other thing I would say is that
dollars are rare are few and far between
regardless of the of the sector of
science that you're in academics
industry government anywhere you go
you're going to be operating on a
shoestring unless you're working in the
plant breeding program in Monsanto or
you can afford to put out five hundred
thousand plots every year so just keep
that in mind okay the next thing I want
to mention is about communicating
science this is something that I'm very
passionate about I think that everyone
here should think about because you have
a lot to communicate about you've a lot
to think about in your careers doing
science and one of them should be how
you talk about your sign
it's okay scientists until fairly
recently used to be in a position of
authority that we were seen as experts
in the field and we worked with facts
and things like this
and so so there's been a change okay so
we need to think about how to speak
about science and how to communicate
that to the general public so these are
just some notes that I have if you don't
know how to speak about science if
you're not a good speaker figure out how
to do that right that's going to be
really important you need to be able to
communicate science not everyone is
gonna argue like a scientist does right
we work with facts we have discourse but
that's not how everyone does it and the
other part about this is is don't just
talk to scientists okay we can publish
in peer reviewed journals we can have
really nice conversations at meeting
scientific meetings that we go to but
there are other people out there that
you need to be talking to and there
they're non scientists who are talking
about science right the bloggers for
example are going to go into that peer
reviewed literature as well and mine it
for what they're interested in so we
need to learn how to talk to these
people and and and and figure out how to
be part of the conversation
and so this is what I'm talking about
just a note about you know bloggers and
things like this people will question
your motivations right that's the whole
goal of some people when they question
science is why did you do this research
and who's funding it okay
so these are the things we need to be
thinking about you may rationalize why
you're doing research on a scientific
level but other people are going to find
other reasons and so this I just want to
bring up these points as things we need
to be thinking about as future
scientists okay the rest of this should
be fairly obviously think creatively
about how you make yourself heard I
don't know what the answer to this is
I'm not good at Twitter I can't even
figure out how to send a tweet that's
just my generation I suppose listen to
what people are seeing saying and teach
as often as you can okay
moving on I work for a company called
advanced biological marketing we are
based in Van Wert Ohio and the company
was founded in the year 2000
our D lab is located in Geneva pictured
here probably the day after we moved in
notice how nice and clean it is it looks
nothing like that right now
so Gary Harmon who was faculty at
Cornell up in Geneva for 40-plus years
was our first chief science officer he
has since retired and Gary Bergstrom
asked me what does that mean well he's
starting another LLC so um so anyway
that this is this is where I work and
this is what advanced biological
marketing does discovery development
production and sales of microbial seed
treatments these microbial seed
treatments are generally referred to in
the industry as biological so when I
refer to biologicals to a scientist that
means a lot of different things in my
industry it means these living seed or
other types of applications we're
working primarily with trichoderma but
also bacillus and rhizobia because we
have products for lots of different
legume crops what we are selling our
spores and in the case of more fragile
organisms like the gram negatives we're
selling encapsulated cells and this is
an important thing because what we do is
we sell a product that is put on the
seed might be combined with agricultural
chemicals like fungicides insecticides
things like this and so and so what
we're actually selling is an important
thing to think about and how these are
used while they're used by the farmer
all the way up to a commercial seed
treater in a lot of different
environments and I put this picture in
just to show some of the differences and
I'll show you more than just this but
this was actually a field trial that was
done this year in a drought situation
where this you can kind of see these
strips and this is typical of some of
the kinds of data that we collect so a
strip trial where this very green strip
was the control standard chemical
treatment and it was not tasseled yet
and these are a couple of biological
treatments our treatment actually one
this particular trial and you can see
some of the differences here in the
different corn and different cobs these
from the standard chemical treatment
didn't oh I guess I have a pointer sorry
um so not that you can see it okay so on
your left our cobs that didn't fill now
they're slower maturing as you can tell
by the lighter color and then those on
the right were our product which is
called say bricks and that contains two
different strains of Trichoderma and it
is matured at this point in the season
and it filled much better again it
didn't feel completely because I said
this was under severe drought stress so
that's a little bit about the company
and what we do but there are a lot of
other players in this game so this is
kind of different pedigrees of the
companies that are also in seed egg
chemicals and now biologicals and this
was fairly accurate until about a month
ago because maybe I'll use this as a
pointer so bear is now in the process of
acquiring Monsanto so if that goes
through that's that's a big deal and Dow
has I think finalized their merger with
DuPont so now oh and Syngenta is no
longer dissing gender that's actually
owned by a Chinese company called Kim
China so so they're now actually just
four players BSF BASF in contrast looks
pretty small
I'm relative to these others so and and
so ABM plays in the same area right
we're we're producing these these
biologicals and all of these companies
are as well so we're a teeny tiny fish
playing in that pond with some quite
large fish okay so what our biologicals
as i said it's this general term you
know there it started out its biological
control the use of one organism to limit
the activity of another and we think
when you look in the literature most
biological control is thinking about
insects
to control insects but we're using fungi
and bacteria as seed treatments and we
can control insects nematodes fungal and
bacterial pathogens there are several
models about how this might work and
I'll get to that in just a moment and
this has obvious potential for
agriculture right if you just think
about Disease Control well that's one
thing that that obviously I'm speaking
to the plant pathology department we
want to control disease but there are a
lot of other things that happen to the
the thing that you can get with most any
biological is growth promotion right you
see plants grow bigger they often look
greener because the genes involved in
photosynthesis are upregulated we see
increased yields and so that benefit is
fairly obvious and so then if you can
apply a safe biological product to the
seed or even as a foliar spray or or
along with the fertilizer maybe you can
reduce the need for agricultural
chemicals which should be good which in
turn should lead to healthier and safer
agricultural systems more sustainable
agricultural systems right so
biologicals have been around a
biological control has been around for
quite some time
the first regicide registered fungal bio
control was t22 and that was done by
gary harmon in 1990 was when it was
registered it had clear demonstrations
of this performance enhancement in the
field and disease control in the field
and but but some of the people are there
are a lot of products that were
developed at that time and since for bio
control and as biologicals
and sometimes this whole industry was
its own worst enemy because there wasn't
a lot of data it was poorly understood
people were brewing these things in
their mom's basement and selling dirty
water right so so there's there's a lot
that have
in the early days that is still biting
us in the butt now right so hopefully
I'll show you how we weave we're moving
beyond that but there are several
control mechanisms that were
hypothesized at that time and and from
your intro a path course that hopefully
you you know some of these antibiotics
you know we're an an organism might
produce a chemical or metabolites that
that is toxic or inhibitory to another
organism this replacement where
something really one organism
outcompetes another and a direct
antagonism which where an organism might
actually kill another organism not
necessarily through an antibiotic and
then performance enhancement mechanisms
there are several those and one of the
main mechanisms that hypothesized is is
nutrient mobilization or bioavailability
and and also through growth promotion
you get with that in increased surface
area which has obvious benefits in terms
of water and nutrient uptake so so so
this is kind of where we started but the
problem was the field performance has
been highly variable there's no question
about that and as I said some of that
came to do with how some of these
products were developed and produced in
the early days and that's what everyone
in this field is trying to overcome so
moving on and what we know now is is
that the mechanisms do include for
disease control do include this niche
replacement antibiotics and Michael
parasitism but also there have been a
lot of studies from dr. Hartman's lab as
well as many others around the world
showing that there are many genes that
are actually turned on when the plant is
colonized by some of these biological
agents and and so we get an induced
systemic resistance of many different
flavors abiotic stress resistance we see
that the changes in plant gene
expression
due to this colonization have a really
big effect on reactive oxygen cycling
that is reactive oxygen species have
some you know our stress molecules and
and when the roots are colonized by
Trichoderma specifically the the genes
in this cycling pathway are upregulated
and so the plant is better able to
buffer stress to protect itself against
stress and and protect its its proteins
and and cell structure so a growth
promotion bio stimulation we know that
yes soil nutrient availability is
important here but we also see that the
changes in plant gene expression up
regulate carbon metabolism and
photosynthesis so we're seeing here is
is the the hypotheses from the early
days weren't wrong but there's more to
it than that that that the organisms are
actually directly affecting how the
plant is expressing its own genes ok ok
so I just want to give a few examples
just in pictures here of some of these
some of the effects and so this is an
experiment that we do in the greenhouse
and for Disease Control just one of many
different types because obviously we can
test for anti-bias on a plate or in the
lab but but what we care most about is
testing these things in the soil and
better yet in the field ok so this is a
greenhouse experiment and what we've
done here is we've infested the soil to
an ld50 so that is if we with
Rhizoctonia and so if we plant 10 wheat
seeds in there we expect to kill 5 of
them ok but that's the SA and so we've
done a good job of that right here we've
got the control and there's the control
and all of these all of the rest of
these were treated with the standard
chemical treatment and what that
standard chemical treatment is a mixture
of fungicides and insecticides and it
just depends on who you buy it from us
exactly what those are so here's a
standard chemical treatment and you see
that that it's got
it actually has three fungicides in it
and it's controlling the Rhizoctonia
better than the control but you when you
throw Trichoderma in that mix then you
see either with the chemical standard
chemical treatment or Trichoderma alone
we see a really big improvement in fact
we have 100 percent germination in the
in the Trichoderma shown here so so
that's one way we do this Si and you
might say oh but you put a fungicide on
the seeds how is strike a dermo which is
a fungus fungus able to grow well
trichoderma first of all we put on
spores which are very resistant and the
other thing is is trichoderma sexually
broadly resistant when two fungicides
which is one of the key reasons why we
use it okay so that's a disease test so
looking at abiotic stress tolerance
these are some plants that have that
we've either applied a water deficit to
when we did that just by determining
what the the 100% water holding capacity
was on that pot weighed it and then
water to 60% of that level and that's
our water stress salt stresses were
watering with a salt solution and the
plants on the Left were did not have
trichoderma on them and the plants on
the right do have Trichoderma so these
pictures I know it's just one plant but
it's a demonstration of the kinds of
kind of effect that you can see here and
as I said earlier we want this to be
able to translate to the field and so we
do a lot of work in the greenhouse but
as fast as we can we move our pipeline
products out to the field so we can get
some some real-world data on them and so
the this was an entire field that was
split down the middle half was planted
with no Trichoderma the other half was
planted with Trichoderma which is in
this case was our say bricks for corn
product carrying two trichoderma strains
that treatment was made at the time of
planting and both of these were also
coated with the standard chemical
treatment okay so they either received
the same base treatment the plants on
the right received our saber extra corn
Trichoderma this is at the end of the
season Illinois in 2012 there was a
severe drought and so you can see the
result the Trichoderma enabled the
plants on the right to continue to live
to produce a yield which you can see in
the in the cobs below it wasn't perfect
ear filling down here but it was far
better than the untreated plants on the
left okay the plants on the Left we
don't have yield data on or what the
yield improvement was on this because
the material on the left was not
harvested it was just too poor so okay
and then finally looking at growth
promotion as I said this is the trait
that is most commonly affected by a
biological product it may or may not
control disease and may or may not
improve abiotic stress but it will it
will like 95 percent the time give you a
bigger plant and so we can we have we
have a saber x product here for rice and
so this is showing standard chemical
treatment alone on the left and say
breaks for rice over that standard
chemical control and you can see the the
larger root mass there and these are the
same number of plants in each pile there
I tell you this is the kind of data I
received sometimes from the field guys
so it's not always the best this was a
pretty good representation so the corn
in the middle we're looking at the
control plant on the left so everything
again everything received the standard
chemical treatment the Saybrook for corn
is in the middle and the k5 as2 on the
right is one of our pipeline products
which is bigger still and these again
are shown in the in the roots on the
right here we have talked a lot about
you know at ABM we talked a lot about
improvements in route biomass but that's
a really hard thing to measure unless
you have a rice
so we made up our owner at the time
right Sean and that is a seven foot PVC
pipe that we put into the ground and we
fill with soil and so that's what we did
with these and we treated them with our
with our treatments the standard
chemical treatment plus the treatments
that are listed up there on the top and
let them grow through the season and
then pulled those tubes out of the
ground and washed away the soil and so
what is shown here is the control say
bricks and then to pipeline products
with a much bigger root mass and so k5
as2 the pipeline product and then omega
which interestingly contains no living
biological contains only a metabolite or
signaling molecule from trichoderma that
is formulated here so so this is really
interesting because again we harvested
this at the end of the season and so
what we got here was a season-long
effect that's something we're still
working out how that's happening so so
anyway so these are some of the growth
promotion data and and and they're just
examples you know this you know wasn't
quantitative data I just want to give
you the idea because you're probably not
used to looking at these kinds of things
okay let's move on now because I've been
talking about our products which are
products in our pipeline products which
are two strains sometimes more but you
know usually that the sweet spot is is
two to four organisms in there so I told
you I talked about the phyto biome so
why do we care about the phyto biome
well there are a lot of reasons why we
might care about this first of all I'm
telling you that we're putting a
biological product we're putting
biological organisms on the seed into
the soil okay so so we know that a corn
plant for example you know it's got into
fights living in it it's gonna have
organisms on the leaf tissue as well
write some of these are causing disease
some are not the soil is teeming with
life and we're putting on another living
organism onto the seat
why
we care about the phyto biome right this
is actually what we're doing and what
we're leveraging in our products it's
just we didn't know it till about five
years ago because I didn't have a name
okay but one of the things that that
that we think about all the time is what
are we recruiting to the seed when we
put our biological there okay and and so
this is this is all in the realm of Fido
biome and I just want to give a plug
here that that ApS our professional
society is very heavily involved in
fighting biomes and if you want to learn
more about it if you're not fully into
that then then you can learn more here
find the roadmap that's been put
together so okay you've probably seen
slides like this before
I just went to web of science and looked
how many times has the term microbiome
or Fido biome been been used over time
and so there's been a real a massive
increase actually since you know 2008
2009 and that's not to say people
weren't thinking about this before then
but I think what's happened is that
sequencing and informatics techniques
have really come along like we can
acquire so much sequence now we can you
know you know back in the day people and
I sorry I said back in the day but you
know a long time ago you know people
were doing PCR on dirt and they're like
why are you doing PCR on dirt you know
what are gonna get out of that well this
is what we can get out of that right we
can we can now look at this with a
luminous sequence or some other kind of
sequencing technologies and we can
actually figure out a lot about what's
there so so there's been a real boom
here and a lot of this has been in
medicine but more and more is is in the
plant world and so so this is something
that's changing along with this along
with the the scientific discoveries in
the Illumina I sorry the sequencing and
bioinformatics that have been on the
rise there's been explosion in a
biological companies ABM has been
working in this area
since 2000 right and these are the
companies and I know I I'm sure I'm
saying a lot actually these are just
some ones I can think of the other day
so all right told you about the sorry
the big players in the field Monsanto
and bear now on pioneer Dow I mean
DuPont Dow are now one but there's also
so those are the ones who have been
around for a while and our traditional
chemical companies and plant breeding
companies that are now in in biologicals
the ones in blue are also companies that
are a little bit older they're kind of
on the fringe is kind of second year
chemical second-tier chemical companies
or breeding companies that are also
playing in this field and then all of
those are that are in green and these
are the ones I know that there are many
more of our the companies that have been
started or started working in
biologicals in the last five years
specifically to leverage phyto biome and
microbiome data okay that so that's all
new so again this this is showing you
kind of the marketer that the space that
that ABM is operating in so every one of
these companies is trying to address
something that's the fundamental problem
in agriculture but agriculture suffers
from the effects of environmental
variability right there's no question
about this that's why we do breeding
that's why we do trialing all over the
country and a lot of different
environments we're trying to address
this problem because if we could get 300
bushel corn every single year everywhere
we planted well that's done and I'd be
out of a job okay but that's not how it
is there's there's a lot of
environmental variability and this is a
plot of some of our data I think just
from last year is showing yields on the
y-axis and location on the right there
are probably about five corn hybrids
that are in this so it's not all one
genotype of the host but it's showing
you that that yields vary by location
and there's no question about that and
what's in blue here
our saber extra corn product again at
Trichoderma product it's increased over
the control or under the control as a
case may be for down there on the on the
left down here but what this shows very
clearly is that there's no relationship
between the performance of a biological
and the yield of a corn plant or even
the location and and so why is that you
know these are this is a question what
is that i don't have the answer right
and so it's one of the things that we
are working on trying to solve and so is
everyone else that i showed on that last
slide everyone is working on this so
okay getting back up phyto biomes can
some of this field level variability to
be explained by its interaction with the
phyto biome there are a lot of factors
out there but we need to think about
what the factors are that we can control
and understand okay
yeah AG biologicals interact with prices
fear and soil inhabitants the plant in a
sphere and the file's fear like oh this
is this is where that corn plant has to
live or whatever whatever crop that you
work on our species that's what it has
to live with and this is an equation
that everyone in here should know and if
you don't then then you should come to
love this because you know you can get a
lot of mileage out of this right so
phenotype right that's disease
resistance that's yield less stress
tolerance genotype we think about us
being the plant right the host crop
environment where you plant it what
chemicals did you apply to it you know
how much rain did you get that year and
then the other part the G by E how does
the how do the the genetics of that host
interact with the environment because
that can if this Therma is really big
then you need to go back to to doing
some breeding and rethinking this
because this is the part that we really
want to control that genetic by
environmental interaction okay so this
is the rest of the slide because what I
want to talk about is what can we
control here what can
what can't we control so there's
phenotype right I already talked about
that that's the trait that's what we're
interested in the plant looking like at
the end of the season genotype we've
thought of as being the host well
there's another genotype here that
people are starting to add and that's
the the biological product the microbial
right
and so Monsanto you know pioneer all
these companies ABM all of us who are
developing microbes we all have the
genome sequence sequences of Australians
we know what what the genotypes are and
so what a lot of research is aimed at is
how does that microbe interact with the
host plant where the phyto biome
research comes into is how does this
interaction relate to this interaction
right because all of this on the end
here that's the environment I already
talked about whether there's no
controlling the weather management
practices you may think you control
management practices but when you send
your material out to a contract
researcher and you say I would like you
to apply 200 pounds of nitrogen and they
apply three and they'll tell you about
it well that's something that you know
it's hard to control and and so and so
you can make recommendations but in the
end the farmer is going to do what the
farmer is going to do because they know
their own farm the best soil type an
environment can't control that
rhizosphere
biology what's in the bulk soil wasn't
that rhizosphere
right and I put this with this kind of
green and yellow dot here is because I
think we're we could be going with the
spider biome research is gaining some
control or at least understanding of
what is in the rhizosphere right the
rhizosphere is going to be different
from what's in the bulk soil and so if
you put a biological on the seed and its
recruiting something or having an
antibiotic effect or something it's
changing what would otherwise be in that
rhizosphere right that's the idea can we
make this a predictable relationship all
right that's where all this is going and
that's what everyone is doing who's
playing in this field
all right then moving on about how we do
that and this is the part where my talk
doesn't really follow the outline that I
put put up in the beginning so so how we
develop strains we're a small company
they're about 40 employees in ABM so we
need to use our resources wisely this is
a correlation matrix among a lot of
different traits that I have assayed for
in the greenhouse or in the lab or in
field trials with with a large set of
our strain collection and that's
Trichoderma and and bacillus okay so
what we want to see is if I can develop
assays that are essentially markers for
good performance okay I don't want to
have to do every single one of these
tests every single time I develop a
trait I want to be able to do a few of
these assays and have that translate to
the field so that's how we do our well
the beginnings of our strange selection
then once everything gets out into the
field for field trials well all bets can
be off sometimes so so anyway the point
is there are a lot of different
phenotypes that go into a good strain
and this varies at a strain level not at
a species level I'm sure that that you
know you all are aware of that and this
correlation of phenotypic effects is
what's going to get us our high
influenced strains and those are the
ones that we advance through our process
so that's just to give you an idea of
what we're looking at we're looking at
traits we're trying to streamline how we
can select for traits and then we
advanced things to the field so this is
an example because we have field trials
every year right and and in 2016 you
know that in 2015 is when the phyto
biomes groups started really getting
going and so we thought in 2016 in our
field trials this is what we're going to
do we're going to do some sampling of
our rhizosphere and we had actually
planned to do some pilot biosphere as
well but well ran out of time and
resources but we set up a really nice
trial in the field in 2016
we applied seed treatments in the spring
when we planted this and this is silage
corn so we had four different biological
treatments six corn hybrids and four
nitrogen levels because we're testing
environmental variability management
practices things like this and we had
three reps there which is fairly typical
and in a lot of field trials especially
of this size so and we had a randomized
complete block design these are our
yield results and again this is silage
so it's it's tons per acre and
experimental one there's actually that
k5 as2 that I had shown previously and
we had significant differences among our
treatments there in the field and just
one note is kind of owing to the
variability that we see in the field
often when we analyze data we use an
alpha point one just so you know that's
how this was analyzed alpha point one
not 0.05 which would be more typical of
a lab kind of experiment so we did this
and I'm gonna go a little bit faster I
thought I'd get you guys out early so so
then we implemented a process which is
to study the the rhizosphere of this and
and so we collected samples root at rye
severe samples in the field isolated DNA
so we could look at 16s and I TS right
because we're working with fungal
products so we want to make sure that we
sa the funding that are present we are
leveraging the the Oxford nanopore
technology the min I on because this is
a technology that has a good price point
we can bring it in-house and we don't
have to wait in line to get our
sequencing done wherever we are and if
we decided we want to put something on a
sequencer that day it takes an hour and
a half to make the library and we can
get it on so and that's the time is
coming down to 10 minutes FYI so so and
then we do the sequencing and then
there's all the downstream which is the
the sequence analysis which I think I
can skip over at this point so
uh just a brief word about the main ion
sequencing this is really if you're not
familiar with it this is a really unique
technology that I guess Peter Schweitzer
is going to get at the core facility
here you can have reads like the power
users have reported reads up to 2 mega
bases long for a single read compared to
alumina which is 1 to 300 depending on
what you're doing here but the error
rates are much higher than Illumina and
so it's a that's a trade-off but if
you're thinking about sequence length
versus depths and that's something that
you can think about this technology is
feel double if we wanted to which we
don't we could take this to the field
actually and run it off the laptop and
the in the back of the truck and they're
continually improving this the this
error rate has actually dropped quite a
bit over the last year just because of
technological changes with that
instrument so so that's a really nice
technology but it also leads to some
challenges for us because we're getting
far fewer reads then then you would for
Illumina and we have a higher error rate
we do get longer reads than an Illumina
which means we can that we can look at
longer sequences in terms of IDs we can
look at the whole ITSs region if we want
to and and the the other negative we
have is that we're interested in looking
at fungal communities and why that's
important is because a lot of the the
software development for analyzing some
of these things is for 16s is for
bacterial genomes not it's not fungal so
and the other negative is time our
bioinformatics
you know I'm kind of having to come up
to speed and some of this stuff so
looking at time there's a really clear
there's a so okay for those of you who
are not working this area chime is a
software and actually now there's chime
to which allows you to look at these
kind of meta genomic microbiome type of
data and and ultimately find where the
differences are identify what is in your
DNA sample and then find out a little
bit about
either well it doesn't tell you function
but you can really interrogate what some
of those different organisms are you
know this is fine to use if you're
working on 16s and if you have really
high read numbers like with aluminum but
if you're working with mini on data as
we are sadly the lower read number and
the higher error rate means that chime
kicks out most of our reads and were
unable to make make it all the way
through the pipeline with more than
about nine features so so our pipeline
is is we generate the data and we use
the Oxford nanopore technology software
to do the basic quality based calling
and quality filtering and then a blast
plus analysis and script based
manipulation of the blast output which
in all honesty is where we need to be
because having the the chyme analysis
looking at reams and reams of data on
for 16s isn't necessarily going to get
me closer to developing a new product
what I want to understand is is a little
bit higher level than that where I don't
need to know all the different strains
that are there what I need to actually
do in the end is find a what the
function of that rhizosphere
is and there are definitely tools out
there to do that but in terms of being
able to go this far as we are this is
actually what I need to be doing right
now so just to quickly run through
massive amounts of data this is what we
found so we sampled that corn field in
2016 and we determined a core microbiome
by filtering based on bits core remember
I'm looking at blast output and
co-occurrence in all three reps and so
we had a lot of data loss and what I'm
showing you here is a 16s results so we
ended up with with the core microbiome
that was fairly small
and oh sorry see is the control Oh as
Omega remember that is contains no
living biological it's just the
metabolite K is K 5 a s 2 and s is our
say bricks for corn products so those
are the four different treatments and
and this was a result so you can see
here so each line in this graph
represents an organism and you're not
expected to read the y-axis because most
of those are uncultured so and and there
were just too many of them and so what's
shown here in blue is that sorry each
line represents one organism and the
color of that line tells me if if that
organism is represented in one of the
treatments or not so for example these
bars down at the bottom have the control
say bricks
k5 as2 and Omega in them okay all four
colors are represented this these
organisms are found in all of the
samples what's interesting is that these
are organisms that are found only in the
control and then these organisms up here
are found only in either the say bricks
Omega or k5 as2 or some combination of
our treatments so that was really
interesting right so that's 16s and then
here's a similar although less organized
representation of what we found in
looking sorry did I say 16s I was 16 s
this is i TS okay
similar representation of what we found
for the the i TS community again there
were several generous so this is on a
genus level that these are listed here
that were present in all treatments some
that were in most of the treatments but
there are some that are present only in
the control only in say bricks only in
k5 s2 and only in omega so what this is
telling us is that we saw changes in
or your community that were correlated
with treatments and and this was a
replicated study and so I feel pretty
good about this because really we just
wanted to see are we are we moving the
that rice for your community away from
what it is as a control or do we have
the ability to achieve it because it
gets to mechanism what are organisms
doing do they only have an effect on
plants because I told you at the outset
that that are that Trichoderma changes
plant gene expression is that all
they're doing well not necessarily right
they are producing metabolites that top
bar up there is Omega this is just a
metabolite produced by trichoderma that
we've applied to the seed okay so our
organism is communicating with the other
microbes in the soil
probably so is it changing how the plant
communicates with with the organisms in
the in the soil
maybe so right this what this does is
get a lot more questions really so this
is another way of looking at i TS data
and and I just did this yesterday
because you know as I said that the the
thing we really want to do is look at
the change in function of the
rhizosphere
right are we changing anything
functionally here and so I just
classified the output from the I TS
analysis into different kind of
lifestyles or functions there in the
rhizosphere and so those are very very
general and what you can see is it and
it's based on the genus level so for
example that first blue category they're
beneficial pathogen that means in that
genus we find both beneficial and
pathogenic organisms it's a real mix and
you can't really say oh it's mostly this
or that and and so so you can see in the
control mostly a mix but you know
there's what what's notable about this
is that there's more diversity in the
control treatment than in the saber X
Omega rk5 as2 which is enter
because we think about AG chemistry as
being something that reduces diversity
in our crops reduces soil diversity
reduces the you know foliar biospheric
community it reduces that diversity and
we think of that as being potentially
bad yes we want to get rid of the
pathogens but we don't want to get rid
of everything else and so seeing a
reduction in diversity here was kind of
interesting to me because okay that you
know this is not that it's the same
thing as what chemicals do but but it's
still a reduction in diversity the other
fascinating thing here is a real
increase in what I called pathogen right
and again I called things pathogen based
on their their genus right that said
there are a lot of things like for
example in Fusarium there are pathogens
there and there are things that are not
pathogenic so so what we've really done
is just change this distribution and and
but it definitely argues against kind of
a niche replacement model here so so
this analysis as with all the other
analyses that I've just shown you
they gets more questions then it does
answers but it really makes us start
thinking about what our products and and
what a biological might contribute to AG
so with that I would like to turn over
there if there's any time for questions
but you know my summary is pretty simple
I mean you know we're assembling storing
consortium that have an effect and a
beneficial effect on crop production I
think what's going to be really valuable
going forward is assembling very large
phenotypic data sets I think probably
everyone in this room here knows that
that's where the bottleneck is in making
progress with all the sequence data is
we need to have the phenotypic data that
goes right along with it and then this
is my teeny tiny little conclusion from
what we did in the twenty sixteen trial
is that our seed treatments that we used
in that corn trial appear to influence
devices for your community membership
and that's what I like so with that if
there was any time for questions I'd be
happy to take some you mean a biological
product yeah so that's something that
we're in that we're initiating now but I
know that that dr. Harmon has done that
we're applying something on a winter rye
so planting it in the fall and then
planting back in in the spring I think
he did this with raspberries and showing
that where the riah had been inoculated
in the fall then they had more
Trichoderma on the raspberries when they
planted them that spring that said and
we also have lots of data on winter
wheat which is planted in the fall and
then you see it in the spring again but
typically um when we think about
perennial crops or something like this
our recommendation is to treat every
year but well yeah we're a company we
want to sell it right but those are data
that that we are still in the process of
acquiring so yeah there was an effective
tractor on gene expression in the plan
what is the magnitude of that change in
gene expression and then do you see a
similar type of gene expression done in
different environments with that okay to
the environment question first you know
we haven't tested it in a lot of
different environments but a lot of
different people around the world have
and it's mainly greenhouse environment
is is where that's being tested and so
it is something that's reproducible seen
over and over again magnitude they are
significant and I'm just trying to you
know I mean statistically significant
and I'm afraid I don't have the
specifics on that but
Oh tents
yeah wait number of genes or magnitude
of change Oh hundreds yeah yeah oh yeah
I appreciate that you have a very
challenging problem it seems if I
understand you correctly that the final
biome varies from field to field just to
start with that what you're trying to do
is to change it to make it more
favorable for plant growth and so you're
trying to match the organisms
[Music]
contributing to the particular field
then once you do that in one year we
change the final biome that presumably
if you keep doing that year after year
then you have the perfect fighter biome
particular preparation right well yes
and no I would say that well okay so
first of all this is something that's in
its infancy
can we actually shift the microbial
community in a given field over time
such that it becomes a generally
agriculturally conducive field well that
remains to be seen you know and I I
think that there should be a lot more
work on organic soils and things like
this but have all the the the microbial
communities been characterized there and
it's a problem of environments right
because every field is different and so
how do we assay every single one of
these fields to determine the to get the
ability to make a global shift to say
that okay what you need to do in this
field is applied this product year over
year over year and then move this into
the into something that's a preferred
microbial community and so then it's
going to be the perfect field so
am i worried about you know putting us
out of business because because if
people start using our products then
they're just going to improve their
soils and that'll be that
not really because because that's a long
way off and I mean that's a long way off
before we can say all that the other
thing that happens is weather right you
have a hot dry year even though you've
done all this work to try and improve
your soils you could kill it right there
right
you could change everything in a single
year so or you have a disease come
through or an insect or something like
this that that brings another microbe
you know changes the chemistry of the
plant that's actually in that soil
remember you're planting plants in here
too and that has influence as well so so
I'm not worried about my job any man
that regard there other reasons why I
might worry about that some but you know
I think that that figuring all this out
is gonna take some time I may be wrong
but because it's a systems biology
problem that also has weather right it's
not just biology it's whether a soil
environment
it's everything so there are human
factors as well so so you know once we
let all the data scientists just be in
charge of everything then we'll probably
be fine but you know we're along with
them in Geneva or other locations all
right Thank You Molly this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu